Football Leaks, infiltriert du Football Leaks.
Für uns ist super, dass wir hinter die Kulissen der Organisation FIFA sehen können und auseinandernehmen können, was sagen die öffentlich und was sagen sie hinter verschlossenen Türen und was entscheiden sie.
Da geht es wirklich um Milliarden, dass die zehn Top-Clubs in der Champions League pro Jahr praktisch eine Milliarde Euro erhalten und damit wird die Struktur in den nationalen Ligen, die wird, zerstört.
Der Fußball mag immer wieder propagieren, dass er für Fairness steht, dass er für bestimmte Werte steht. Wir sehen davon in den Dokumenten nichts.
Die Football Leaks, das einzige Thema im Rasenfunk, was sich so ein bisschen unserem Formaten verweigert. Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit heißt es normalerweise im Tribünengespräch und normalerweise reden wir so lange über ein Thema, bis es zu Ende erzählt ist. Jetzt laufen die Football Leaks aber und deswegen müssen wir immer und immer wieder nachlegen. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 27. Mein Name ist Max Hakob-Ost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass wir jetzt schon zum vierten Mal diesen Themenkomplex hier behandeln können. Das heißt, wenn euch das Ganze ganz neu sein sollte oder ihr nochmal Lust habt, das von Anfang an nachzuhören, dann fangt doch an mit Kurzpass 35. Macht weiter mit Tribünengespräch Nummer 10, dann Tribünengespräch Nummer 20 und dann hört ihr hier die Nummer 27. Und ich freue mich, dass ich ihn wieder bei mir in der Leitung begrüßen kann. Rafael Buschmann vom Spiegel, Ed Raffanelli bei Twitter. Servus, Rafael. Es wird eine schöne Tradition, dass wir uns hier zu den Football Leaks treffen. Die Abstände werden auch immer kürzer, was vor allem mit eurem Veröffentlichungsrhythmus zu tun hat. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange wir das noch so weiterziehen können. Bis ins Jahr 2030, 2040, 2050. Was ist dein Gefühl?
Daran sieht man, wie viel unerzählte Geschichten im Fußball noch rumliegen und in der Fußballbranche noch rumliegen. Wie oft wir eigentlich, also es geht uns ja genauso, wenn wir in die Daten gucken, haben wir ja ganz oft nach einer Veröffentlichung das Gefühl, jetzt ist alles erzählt. Und jetzt haben wir einen Großteil der Fußballbranche ausgeleuchtet. Und dann setzen wir uns nach einer Woche wieder hin, gucken in die Daten und stellen fest, ach du liebe Güte, da ist noch so viel, was wir noch erzählen müssen, weil es die Öffentlichkeit interessiert, weil es wichtig für Fans, für möglicherweise Spieler, Funktionäre, Manager ist, weil von vielen dieser Dinge große Teile der Öffentlichkeit eben nichts wissen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch so weitergehen, vor allem sollten die Leaks weiter reintröpfeln, aber da sprechen wir jetzt gleich ausführlicher drüber. Es gibt zu dem jetzigen Stand zwei Veröffentlichungen, also in den letzten beiden Spiegel-Ausgaben lohnt es sich, rein zu gucken. Es gab zwei Dokus, einmal im ersten und einmal im NDR, wobei die, glaube ich, auch in der ARD gesendet wurde, und auch verschiedene Podcast-Auftritte. Es gibt auch einen Football Leaks-Podcast. All das habe ich jetzt mal stellvertretend für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, konsumiert und werde auf Grundlage dieser Informationen mit Rafael sprechen. Ich möchte euch aber sehr ans Herz legen, beschäftigt euch mit diesem Themenkomplex noch mal selbst, so wirklich kann man das alles immer erst glauben, wenn man es selbst gehört oder gelesen hat. Denn wir werden hier mit hohen Zahlen um uns werfen und mit vielen Namen. Also, das erspart euch nicht, dass ihr euch selbst ein bisschen einarbeitet, auch wenn es manchmal ein bisschen weh tut, wenn man ein Fußball-Romantiker ist. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich noch Nils, Philipp, Lorenz, Schmi und André. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter und Supporterinnen. Und wir freuen uns sehr, dass sie uns helfen, dass das hier werbe- und sponsorenfrei bleiben kann. Allein von Hörern und Hörern finanziert. Das ist vielleicht dann auch die Finanzierung, in der man am wenigsten anfällig ist für Deals, über die wir jetzt gleich noch sprechen werden mit Sponsoren. Also herzlichen Dank dafür. Ihr haltet uns auf der sauberen Seite des Fußballs. Und zum Dank gibt es für die Supporterinnen und Supporters Sticker. Wie ihr die bekommt, habe ich euch in eine E-Mail geschickt. Solltet ihr diese nicht bekommen haben und ihr euch aber registriert haben, auf rasenfunk.de/rsc, dann meldet euch bei mir. Dann lösen wir das irgendwie anders. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal reingehen. In diesen Themenkomplex, Rafael und ich würde gerne mit Gianni Infantino beginnen. Ich habe schon überlegt, ob man im Trumpschen Sinne jetzt mal anfangen müsste, denjenigen, die sich da nicht mehr mit sauberer Weste durch den Fußball bewegen, irgendwelche Adjektive zukommen lassen könnte. Greedy Gianni ist mir da eingefallen. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich jetzt wirklich Donald Trump kopieren möchte. Aber um den ging es in vielen Teilen der Football Leaks. Und das erste Thema, was ihn betrifft, ist seine Zeit als UEFA-Generalsekretär und das Financial Fair Play. Im Jahr 2014 hatten sowohl PSG als auch Manchester City große Probleme mit dem Financial Fair Play. Denn sie hatten zwar auf dem Papier keine zu hohen Verluste geschrieben, aber das nur durch Sponsoring-Verträge in, sagen wir mal, merkwürdiger Höhe. Bei PSG überwies die katarische Tourismusbehörde 215 Millionen Euro pro Jahr. Eine hinzugezogene Agentur, die den Wert des Vertrags dann marktüblich bewerten sollte, kam auf nicht einmal 3 Millionen Euro, die dieses Sponsoring eigentlich wert war. Also nochmal kurz, 215 Millionen Euro im Jahr erhalten. Eine unabhängige Agentur sagt, naja, das hätte eigentlich den marktüblichen Wert von 3 Millionen Euro gehabt. Und ähnlich war es bei Manchester City. Sponsoring-Verträge über 50 Millionen Euro waren mindestens 80 Prozent zu teuer und wie bei PSG gab es auch eine sehr große und zu große Nähe zwischen Sponsoren und Vereinen. Was dazu geführt hätte? Eigentlich hätte man bei City zum Beispiel ein Defizit von 188 Millionen Euro gehabt. Das hätte gegen das Financial Fair Play so dermaßen verstoßen, wie selten etwas gegen etwas verstoßen hat. Und das fiel auch der UEFA auf. Das Gremium des Club Financial Control Bodies leitete eine Untersuchung ein, die dann auch gravierende Verstöße offenlegte und dann Rafael Auftritt Gianni Infantino. Was ist dann passiert?
Danach hat der Fußball zurückgeschlagen, wie wir ihn jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren in diesen über 70 Millionen Dokumenten sehr ausführlich kennengelernt haben. Und zwar eine gute Idee, mit schäbigen Deals zunichte zu machen. Die gute Idee ist das Financial Fair Play. Das ist in der Tat der Geist des Financial Fair Play. Es ist ja eine gute Idee, zu sagen, dass Vereine nur so viel Geld ausgeben dürfen, wie sie selbst auch einnehmen. Das ist ja der Grundgedanke.
Damit der Wettbewerb fair bleibt.
Absolut. Damit es kein finanzielles Doping gibt. Damit nicht einfach irgendein Multimilliardär sich einfach einkaufen kann, aufbumpen kann und dann dadurch den Wettbewerb im Prinzip zerstört, weil er sich jeden Spieler kaufen kann, weil er sich jedes Stadion kaufen kann, weil er sich eine Infrastruktur bauen kann, die kein anderer hat. Das soll damit eingedämmt werden, um nach wie vor Vereine auch davor zu schützen, beispielsweise von einer Heuschrecke übernommen zu werden und nach kürzester Zeit wieder ausgespuckt zu werden, wie wir es beispielsweise bei 1860 München gesehen haben. Diese Grundidee des Financial Fairplays wird gestützt durch zwei Säulen. Das kann man vergleichen mit einer Staatsanwaltschaft und einem Richter, die bei der UE versitzen, die beide unabhängig von der UE von Funktionären die finanziellen Geschehnisse bei den Vereinen bewerten sollen. Das heißt, die Staatsanwaltschaft ist dafür zuständig, sich die gesamten Bilanzen und Bücher anzusehen und dann einen Vorschlag, also eine Anklage an den Richtertisch zu geben und der Richter entscheidet, was am Ende für eine Strafe dabei rumkommt. Eigentlich ein sinnvolles, gutes System. Es wird dann nicht sinnvoll und nicht gut, wenn sich gegen alle Regeln der UEFA-Generalsekretär in Person von Gianni Infantino in genau diese Form der Anklage und des Urteils einmischt. Und zwar genau dazwischen, indem er mehr oder minder selbstständig und eigenständig anfängt, Deals mit den Vereinen auszumachen, bei denen er ihnen dann Summa summarum und Pi mal Daum erlaubt, welche Marktwerte von Sponsoring-Verträgen noch möglich sind, welche machbar sind, an welcher Stelle die Vereine dann Grenzen erreichen oder eben nicht erreichen. Das ist dann ein dauerhaftes Aufweichen der eigentlich vorgegebenen Gesetzesgrenzen. Man könnte das im Alltag damit vergleichen, wenn man die Rückzahlung eines Kredits hat. Der Kredit liegt bei 320.000 oder 340.000 und man soll 1.500 Euro im Monat zurückzahlen. Man kann es nicht zurückzahlen und dann setzt man sich mit dem Banker an einen Tisch und der Banker sagt dann einfach von sich aus, na gut, dann machen wir mal 300 Euro oder 200 Euro oder 100 Euro. Man hat dadurch einen Vorteil allen anderen gegenüber im Hauskauf, im Autokauf, im sonstigen, der deutlich über das Maß hinausgeht, was normalerweise erlaubt wäre. Den Fußball bedeutet ein solches Hinausgehen über dieses Maß, dass Clubs wie Manchester City, wie Paris Saint-Germain in der Lage sind, sich im Wettbewerb eine solche Vormachtstellung, also in der Champions League beispielsweise eine solche Vormachtstellung zu erkämpfen, mit der sie sehr weit im Wettbewerb kommen, also ins Achtelfinale, Viertelfinale, Halbfinale und auf diese Art und Weise einen immensen finanziellen Vorteil erringen, also sehr, sehr viel Geld verdienen, dadurch, dass sie sehr viel Geld eingesetzt haben. Und über kürzeste Zeit sehen wir jetzt bei Manchester City aus einem im Prinzip aufgeblähten Investorenverein ein profitables Unternehmen zu machen, das Geld verdient, aber das eben Geld verdient, abseits der Regularien, die vorher möglich waren.
Da hängen jetzt noch viele Anschlussfragen dran. Ich möchte aber, bevor ich mit dir über den Themenkomplex unter welchen moralischen Bedingungen man sein Geld verdient, diskutieren, noch kurz dann zurückgehen zu dem, was dann passiert ist. Also Gianni Infantino hat dann einen Deal ausgehandelt, sowohl mit Paris Saint-Germain als auch mit Manchester City bei PSG. Zum Beispiel ging es darum, dass der Sponsoringvertrag, der ja mit 3 Millionen bewertet wurde von der Agentur Octagon und aber 215 Millionen Euro pro Jahr wert war, der wurde auf, haltet euch fest, 100 Millionen Euro runtergestuft. Also da hat es immer so richtig rasiert. Die Differenz durfte dann aber sogar noch durch andere katarische Sponsoren ausgeglichen werden. Und PSG musste 20 Millionen Euro Strafe zahlen. Bei Manchester City bewegte sich dann letztlich die Strafe in ähnlichen Rahmen, aber es passierte eben nicht. Was bei anderen Vereinen schon passiert war, bei viel geringeren Verstößen, nämlich ein Ausschluss aus den Wettbewerben wie zum Beispiel der Champions League. Jetzt habe ich mir die Frage gestellt. Teile davon wusste man ja schon. Man wusste von den Untersuchungen, man wusste, dass sich PSG und City, dass man sich da geeinigt hat und man wusste ja auch, dass das außerhalb dieser Strafkammer vollzogen wurde. Was konnte denn jetzt Football Leaks zu dieser Geschichte dazu addieren?
Dass im Prinzip sowohl die Strafkammer als auch der Richtertisch nahezu machtlos sind, wenn am Ende der UEFA-Generalsekretär das Ganze in seine Hände nimmt und anfängt, Entscheidungen an den bestehenden Regularien vorbeizufällen. Mit solchen Ausnahmeregelungen, die Gianni Infantino implementiert hat, und das ist ja eigentlich die große Leistung der Dokumente, dass man herausarbeiten kann, dass es wirklich von einer Person dazu führt, dass der Wettbewerb ausgehebelt werden kann und dass die Regularien, die eigentlich sinnvoll sind, zunichte gemacht werden. Dass diese Form der Enthüllung normalerweise dafür sorgen müsste, dass alle anderen Vereine in der Champions League, aber auch die mittleren und kleinen Vereine in der Euro League und in den jeweiligen Leagues eigentlich aufscheinen müssten und sagen müssten, was betreiben wir denn hier? Also das ist ja ein Wettbewerb, der mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wird, wenn der FC Sillon aus dem Wettbewerb ausgeschlossen wird. Aber Manchester City dann mit der puren Kraft von Andelten und einer wahnsinnigen Geldmacht, die UEFA solange unter Druck setzt, bis der UEFA-Generalsekretär dann in einer Art Staatsstreich dazu ermuntert oder mithilft, solche Settlements zu erarbeiten und auszuarbeiten, dann ist das ja nichts anderes als das komplette Aushebeln dessen, woran dieser Fußballverbund von europäischen Vereinen glaubt. Und dann kann man auch sagen, ist das Financial Fair Play, wird ad absurdum geführt, dann wird die UEFA ad absurdum geführt, dann werden die einzelnen nationalen Ligen ad absurdum geführt. Woran soll man an so einer Stelle im Fußball glauben, wenn es tatsächlich möglich ist, dass solche Top-Funktionäre ihre Entscheidungsgewalt so dermaßen ausnutzen, um am Ende bestimmte Vereine so profitieren zu lassen. Also wie groß wäre der Aufschrei, wenn so etwas mit einzelnen Unternehmen in einem Staat passieren würde?
Naja, auch nicht so groß, wenn wir uns die Cum-Ex-Berichterstattung oder die Cum-Ex-Berichterstattung angucken, oder?
Bei Cum-Ex ist es ja nochmal etwas anderes, weil da ist es ein Ausnutzen einer rechtlichen Lücke. Es ist nicht das Befördern der rechtlichen Lücke durch Politiker, zumindest nicht durch solche Spitzenpolitiker. Durch manche Politiker schon, aber eben nicht durch solche Spitzenpolitiker. Hier ist es der zweitmächtigste Funktionär im Fußball, der UEFA-Generalsekretär und heutige mächtigste Funktionär im Fußball, der so dermaßen in die Regularien dieses Sports eingreift. Regularien, die vorher in zahlreichen Sitzungen zwischen den einzelnen Verbänden, Vereinen und Ligen erarbeitet wurden. Und hebelt sie auf diese Art und Weise aus und stellt sich danach auch noch hin und sagt, ich habe doch nichts Unrechtes gemacht. Diese Art von Dealerei ist Grundlage dieses Financial Fairplays und gehört dazu. Wenn das die Grundlage ist, dass man einen Sponsoring-Vertrag, der bei 200 plus Millionen liegt, aber eigentlich nur knapp über 2 Millionen wert ist, am Ende einpendelt auf 100 Millionen, was ist denn das für eine für eine Dealerei? Das ist nichts anderes als im Prinzip ein Q-Handel, den man mit den Reichen und Mächtigen erzeugt, damit, wie Gianni Infantino es selbst sagt, diese weiterhin in der UEFA bleiben und nicht auswüchsen und am Ende eine Super League oder sonstiges gründen.
Da greifen wir dann noch vor über ein Thema, auf ein Thema, was wir auch gleich noch besprechen wollen. Andererseits kann man ja aber auch argumentieren, die Drohkulisse von PSG und Manchester City war ja real und auch der Ton, der ja jetzt offengelegt wird, dadurch, dass man über Football Leaks die direkte Kommunikation zwischen Gianni Infantino und den Beteiligten bei den Vereinen hat, war ja auch sehr rau und drohend. Also kann man nicht auch irgendwie Verständnis haben dafür, dass man versucht, den Super-GAU in Anführungszeichen zu umgehen, dass diese Vereine wirklich nicht in der Champions League spielen. Also ich spiele jetzt den Advocatus Diabolis und das fühlt sich auch nicht ganz so gut an, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich finde, so ganz überraschend kann es ja auch nicht, dass der UEFA-Generalsekretär versucht, dem entgegenzuwirken. Und was mich dann eher verwundert ist, wo bleibt denn der Aufschrei der anderen beteiligten Vereinen der Champions League? Das hast du ja schon genannt, der bleibt aus. Und das, der ausbleibt, sagt ja auch etwas aus. Vielleicht darüber, wie andere Vereine diesen Themenkomplex bewerten. Vielleicht sehen die es alle gar nicht so schlimm.
Also ich habe ja im Fußball gelernt, dass nahezu niemand den anderen für kriminelle, für dunkle Machenschaften kritisiert, weil im Fußball nahezu dauerhaft diese kleine Blase von Menschen immer wieder untereinander, voneinander profitiert. Das heißt, keiner will eigentlich den anderen angreifen und das ist auch hier der Fall. Ich möchte aber deinen Herangehen oder beziehungsweise deine Argumentation etwas weiter nach vorne führen, weil diese Argumentation zu sagen, dann drohen sie halt so sehr, dass sie irgendwann vielleicht rausgehen und dadurch die UEFA verlassen, das ist eine Drohkulisse, die wirkt und die die UEFA unter Druck setzt, das ist eine nachvollziehbare Argumentation. Wobei ich immer, also auch in dem Super League-Thema, immer wieder mir selbst die Frage gestellt habe, was passiert denn an einem bestimmten Punkt, an dem die UEFA so viel den absoluten Top Clubs gegeben hat, dass sie ihn gar nicht mehr geben kann?
Also verstehst du, das ist, also wo ist die Grenze quasi?
Es gibt keine mehr. Die UEFA ist dadurch, dass sie in den letzten rechten Perioden rund um die Champions League, rund um die Austragung von europäischen Spielen, auch im Zuge des Financial Fairplays, dem Verein so massiv entgegengekommen ist, dass Gianni Infantino so viel Macht abgegeben hat, auch an die Vereine und ihnen im Prinzip die Möglichkeit gegeben hat, sich an den Financial Fairplay vorbeizumogeln. Durch diese Geisteshaltung und durch diese, na ja auch, wie soll man es ausdrücken, eine Anti-Compliance-Bewegung, die dort entstanden ist, ist dem Klub so viel Macht gegeben worden, dass sie die UEFA jetzt schon nicht mehr brauchen. Also sie könnten jederzeit sich selbst organisieren, sie könnten jederzeit einen eigenen Wettbewerb gestalten, sie könnten jederzeit sagen, wir gehen eben jetzt hier raus. Weil auf der einen Seite sind es die Investorenclubs, die sagen, das Financial Fair Play blockiert uns. Diese ständige Auseinandersetzung mit dem UEFA-Verband oder auch teilweise mit der FIFA, das ist für uns mittlerweile lästig, das wollen wir nicht mehr. Auf der anderen Seite sehen wir ja, dass die Traditionsclubs etwas ähnliches planen, weil sie sagen, solange die UEFA uns nicht weiter schützen kann, solange die UEFA uns nicht noch mehr Geld geben kann, solange wir nicht noch reicher aus dem einzelnen Wettbewerb werden, müssen wir uns neue Gedanken dazu machen, wie wir uns selbst aufstellen. Das heißt, die UEFA hat sich selbst in eine solche Machtlosigkeit getrieben, weil sie eben ihre eigenen Regeln nicht konsequent durchsetzen konnte. Was wäre denn passiert, wenn Gianni Infantino gesagt hätte, gut, dann schmeißen wir jetzt Manchester City und Paris Saint-Germain im Jahr 2014 aus der Champions League raus.
Wäre auch ein interessanter Wettbewerb gewesen und die TV-Gelder nicht gleich eingebrochen. Aber sie wären auch überzogen worden mit einer Klagewelle. Und da kommen wir dann in so einen juristischen Bereich rein. Wir haben es hier eben auch einfach zu tun mit einem von einer privaten Institution oder einer gemeinnützigen Institution organisierten Wettbewerb. Und wir haben ja aber auch noch so etwas wie ein EU-Wettbewerbsrecht und als Investor habe ich ja ein Interesse, dass ich schon die Möglichkeit habe, 1,29 Milliarden Euro in irgendein Projekt reinzustecken, wenn ich denn das Gefühl habe, das dürfe so sein. Also wir kommen hier ja auch in juristische Bereiche, die noch gar nicht wirklich ausgeleuchtet wurden.
Ich bin gerade ziemlich begeistert, weil das die Diskussion ist, die mir im Moment in deutschem Sportjournalismus und allzu komplett fehlt. Das ist eigentlich genau die Diskussion, auf die wir auch versuchen, abzuzielen. Wir haben jetzt tolle Berichte dazu im Guardian gefunden und tolle Fazit-Resümee-Berichte in der New York Times gefunden, die sich genau mit diesem Thema beschäftigen. In Deutschland ist es in allzu null ausgeleuchtet.
Es gibt auch eine niederländische Hochschule, die dazu was Tolles geschrieben hat. Werde ich alles verlinken in den Show Notes.
Exakt, Herr Anton Duval hat dazu auch etwas richtig Gutes gemacht. Das ist für mich die Kernfrage. Ist der Sport im Jahr 2018 noch in der Lage, sich mit den sportpolitischen Instanzen, die er sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten aufgebaut hat, weiterhin in der Lage selbst zu verwalten? Oder ist es nicht eher so, dass der Fußball aus der Sportgerichtsbarkeit mittlerweile entwachsen ist und mittlerweile genauso behandelt werden müsste, wie jede Großindustrie, die es in der freien Wirtschaft ergibt, die normaler Gerichtsbarkeit unterliegt, die normalen Gesetze unterliegt, und sich eben nicht seine eigenen Gesetze erschaffen kann? Es ist kein Zufall, dass gerade in den Fußball immer mehr Oligarchen, Scheichs, Großinvestoren aus Amerika oder aus Asien hineindrängen, weil der Fußball eine der wenigen Branchen, neben dem Kunsthandel beispielsweise, ist, wo du deine eigenen Werte ermitteln kannst. Eine Ablösesumme wird von keiner unabhängigen Instanz entwickelt, sondern eine Ablösesumme wird festgelegt zwischen zwei Vereinen, die sich Pi mal Daumen auf einen Wert einigen, zwischen zwei Spielern. Diese Form von Geldflüssen ist vollkommen intransparent. Es ist machbar mit solchen Ablösesummen, mit so einem Transfer gebaren Gelder in Milliardenhöhe von der einen Stelle zu anderen zu verschieben. Wenn wir einen Schritt zurückgehen und daran denken, dass das Bankensystem im Jahr 2008, 2009 zusammengebrochen ist, dass rund um die Finanzkrise die Geldwäschengesetze extrem verschärft wurden, mittlerweile Banken sehr viel freilegen müssen und wenn wir uns dann das totale El Dorado im Fußball für Investoren vorstellen, wo es all diese Regularien nicht gibt und wo man Gelder aus dem Diamantenhandel, wo man Gelder aus dem Ölhandel, wo man Gelder aus dem Waffenhandel und sonst was zwischen Vereinen hin und her schieben kann, ohne dass es groß auffällt, weil man hat Zwischenhändler, man hat Agenten, man hat Berater, man hat Firmen, die man in Steueroasen parken kann und auf die Art und Weise verschleiern kann und Geldflüsse laufen kann, laufen lassen kann. All das müsste normalerweise genauso untersucht werden, wie es das im Bankenwesen der Fall ist, wie es an der Börse der Fall ist. Tut es aber nicht, weil der Fußball sich immer wieder auf diese Sportgerichtsbarkeit zurückfallen lässt und sagt, das ist traditionell etwas, was der Sport selbst aufgebaut hat, was eine Ausnahmestellung für den Sport ist, dass die Sportgerichtsbarkeit im Prinzip die höchste Verwaltungsstufe ist und wir sehen ja auch, dass ganz viele der Sachen, die wir aufgedeckt haben, dann in erster Linie mit wohlwollen Worten von der FIFA oder UEFA begleitet werden, die dann sagen, wir werden ermitteln, wir werden uns das angucken. Danach hört man in der Regel nichts mehr. Es gibt dann irgendwelche fadenscheinigen Untersuchungen, die aber nach kürzester Zeit wieder eingestellt werden, eingedampft werden oder mit sehr geringen Strafen ausgestattet werden. Der Druck der Öffentlichkeit wird dazu immer größer. Wir sehen ja mittlerweile sogar Banner in Stadien und wir sehen, dass sich auch Fans dagegen wirklich auflehnen und feststellen, dass es hier nicht nur darum geht, ob jemand mal 5,50 Euro an Steuern hinterzieht, sondern dass es ein System, der Gier gibt, dass einfach nahezu jede Regularien, die der Sport selbst erfunden hat oder die ihm dann auch durch Sportgerichtsbarkeiten aufgelegt werden, ohne Probleme umgehen kann. Solange das der Fall ist, solange es nicht äußere Schwerpunktsstaatsanwaltschaften gibt oder externe Behörden, die auf Due Diligence, auf Compliance achten, die eine Art Clearing House sind, durch das zum Beispiel Geldflüsse laufen und Zahlungen laufen, die dann feststellen würden, dass Manchester City nahezu alle großen Sponsoring-Verträge zusätzlich aufpumpt, dass es eine extreme Nähe gibt zwischen dem Geldgeber aus Abu Dhabi und zwischen dem Verein. Die Gelder laufen nur über unterschiedliche Firmen und die Firmen verschleiern teilweise eben die Herkunft der Gelder, solange das nicht in einer Art Clearing House oder in einer unabhängigen Instanz wirklich offengelegt wird, auf die dann Menschen wie Gianni Infantino keinen Zugriff haben oder keine Möglichkeit haben einzugreifen. Solange ist der Fußball nicht in der Lage, eine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wieder zurück zu erlangen, weil die hat er nämlich tatsächlich in den letzten zehn Jahren, minimum zehn Jahren, vollkommen verloren.
Ja, ich meine, da ist natürlich die Frage, ob der Fußball überhaupt will, dass das passiert, denn aktuell kann man wunderbar Geld verdienen im Fußball, aber darauf will ich gar nicht hinaus. Wir greifen jetzt ein bisschen auf die Diskussion vor, aber ist nicht der Kern dieser Problematik eigentlich, dass die beiden gemeinnützigen Verbände UEFA und FIFA, die eben dann quasi ihr eigenes Kontrollsystem etabliert haben, das nicht funktioniert, dass die in der Schweiz beheimatet sind, mit einem ganz eigenen Rechtsverständnis, mit ganz anderen Zugriffsrechten auf solche Verbände. Und ich frage mich, wenn wir jetzt über so juristische Konsequenzen sprechen, welche Zugriffsmittel gäbe es eigentlich von staatlichen Institutionen, also beispielsweise von der EU oder jetzt auch hier in Deutschland. So wie ich es verstehe, sind die einzigen Druckmittel, die da vorhanden sind, neben eben politischen Druckmitteln, dass man auch auf die Schweizer Behörden zugeht, dass man die eigenen Verbände in die Pflicht nimmt und sagt, solange ihr in einer solchen Struktur operiert, wollen wir, ich bewege mich jetzt auf dünnem juristischen Eis, ich weiß nicht genau, was davon möglich ist, es geht jetzt nicht darum, die Gemeinnützigkeit zu entziehen, aber man kann doch nur die politisch verantwortlich machen, weil das eigentliche Problem liegt in der Schweiz und da kommen wir ja irgendwie nie ran.
Man kann im Prinzip nicht reinschauen, man hat kaum Offenlegungen von Geldflüssen. Es ist nahezu unmöglich festzustellen, wie die Gelder am Ende wirklich reingehen und verteilt werden. Ich glaube persönlich, dass du die Macht der Ligen und der einzelnen nationalen Verbände vollkommen überschätzt. Ich kann es nicht komplett trennen, wenn ich auf die Super League-Geschichte eingehe. Sie zeigt sehr entschieden, wie die Vereine problemlos am Rücken der Vereine und Verbände vorbeigegangen können. Auch an so einem Liga-Verband wie der DFL. Christian Seifert wusste im Jahr 2016 bis zum Schluss nicht, was die Top-Klubs da eigentlich veranstalten. Das sehen wir aus seinen Mails, in denen er vollkommen überrascht ist von dem Ergebnis, das am Ende bei rumkommt. Solange diese Ahnungslosigkeit existiert, weil sie existiert durch die Intransparenz der Vereine und des Agierens der Vereine, ist es für die Liga und für die nationalen Verbände extrem schwierig, irgendeinen Druck auf die großen Verbände auszuüben.
Also müsste man an die Vereine ran?
Generell müsste es einfach im Fußball, also wenn der Fußball nicht anders ist. Ich bin vielleicht dafür zu romantisch und möchte nicht zu naiv wirken. Ich bin schon ein absoluter Realist, wenn es um die Umsetzbarkeit vieler Dinge geht. Und trotzdem wundere ich mich natürlich an mancher Stelle, dass es so wenige kritische Stimmen aus dem Fußball selbst gibt, die einfach sagen, so wie der Sport im Moment organisiert ist, so wie er gestaltet ist, so intransparent wie die Geldflüsse ablaufen, möchten wir das nicht mehr. Wir möchten, dass wir die Glaubwürdigkeit bei den Menschen da draußen nach all den FIFA, UEFA, Football League-Skandalen zurückbekommen und möchten uns hier mit einem sauberen Konzept auseinandersetzen. Aber das ist irrsinnig zu glauben, dass das wirklich aus dem Fußball herauskommt, selbst entsteht, weil einfach jeder im Fußball im Moment Geld verdienen kann. Ich habe den Spruch eines Beraters gehört, der gesagt hat, wer im Fußball nach einem halben Jahr nicht Millionär ist, der ist einfach stockdorf. Er hat mir dann gesagt, selbst die Stockdoben gehen mit sechsstelligen Beträgen raus. Das ist im Moment etwas, da will niemand den anderen in irgendeiner Form unter Druck setzen oder will dieses Geschäftsmodell in irgendeiner Form beschädigen. Ich prognostiziere, dass in den nächsten Jahrzehnten zig Ermittlungsverfahren auf den Fußball zurollen werden. So wie es sich funktioniert, wie sich Spieler und Berater an diesem Sport in den letzten Jahren angefangen haben zu bereichern, so wie sie ihn ausnehmen wie eine Gans, das habe ich noch in keiner anderen Branche gesehen. Wir beschäftigen uns mit vielen unterschiedlichen Branchen. Wir haben uns mit Airbus und der Luftfahrt beschäftigt. Wir haben uns mit dem Militär beschäftigt, wo auch sehr viele Gelder umgesetzt werden. Wir haben uns mit dem Bankenwesen in den letzten Jahren investigativ beschäftigt. Aber dass wir auf einen solchen Selbstbedienungsladen wie den Fußball gestoßen sind, ist mir zumindest noch nicht untergekommen. Wir haben 2016, als wir die Fälle rund um Jorge Mendez und Cristiano Ronaldo veröffentlicht haben und gezeigt haben, mit welchen Steuermodellen sie gearbeitet haben, sehen wir heute, dass es langsam Auswirkungen dieser Entwicklung auf juristischer Ebene gibt. Jorge Mendez läuft ein Ermittlungsverfahren in Bezug auf seine Steuersituation. Mittlerweile sind es fünf oder sechs Länder, die sich zusammengeschlossen haben und die Transfers von Jorge Mendez der letzten Jahre überprüfen. Mittlerweile sind sie auf einen Gesamtwert von über einer Milliarde gekommen. Eine Milliarde Transfervolumen eines einzelnen Beraters, die von Steuerbehörden aus unterschiedlichen Ländern geprüft werden. Wenn man sich das anguckt, kann man ein bisschen prognostizieren, wie lange solche Ermittlungsverfahren laufen werden. Das wird Jahre in Anspruch nehmen. Wir sehen in Amerika, wie lange das FBI mittlerweile an der FIFA rumdoktert und wie lange dort die Ermittlungsverfahren rund um den Verband laufen, wie lange die Ermittlungsverfahren in der Schweiz gegen die FIFA laufen. All das führt dazu, dass der Sport peu à peu ein bisschen seiner Unabhängigkeit abgeben muss. Weil jedes dieser Verfahren, das am Ende dann auch dazu führt, dass es Anklagen gibt, dass es Urteile geben wird, wird dazu führen, dass der Druck auf den Sport immer größer wird, von außen eine Kontrollbehörde auf den Sport schauen zu lassen. Niemand kauft den Sport mehr ab, dass er sich selbst reinnehmen kann. Also weder wir noch, glaube ich, irgendein Experte da draußen.
Ja, ist ja wie mit der katholischen Kirche. Aber das ist für mich nämlich die eigentliche Kernfrage. Und da muss ich jetzt mir die Experten suchen, die mal versuchen, mir das juristisch zu erklären. Wir reden darüber, wie man jetzt einzelner Menschen innerhalb dieses Systems habhaft werden kann in dem Sinne, dass man sie dazu zwingt, Geldströme offen zu legen. Und dann, im meisten Fall geht es dann darum, Steuern nachzuteilen. Und das ist super, weil da kommt Geld wieder zurück zu der Gemeinschaft, die den Fußball ja auch auf ihrem Rücken trägt. Aber die große Frage nämlich, was kann man tun, dass staatlich organisierte oder wirklich unabhängige Kontrollgremien existieren in diesem System Fußball, das eben seinen Sitz in der Schweiz hat, die konnte mir bisher noch niemand so richtig beantworten, weil es, glaube ich, auch eine sehr komplexe Frage ist. Und ich finde auch nämlich, dass das der eigentliche Kern aller Geschichten ist. Und ihr spielt das immer nur über Bande. Ihr zeigt mit einem auch sehr moralisch erhobenen Zeigefinger, wie verkommen das System geworden ist und dass die Kontrollmechanismen nicht greifen. Und die Konsequenz daraus, also die erste Konsequenz ist Empörung. Die zweite Konsequenz sollte sein, ich schalte meinen Kopf an und überlege, was könnte man dagegen tun. Und da kommen wir dann eben immer in diesen juristischen Bereich rein. Und mich wundert das nämlich auch, dass das nicht die Diskussion ist. Dass ich da auch keine Politiker höre. Also Cem Özdemir hat sich jetzt mal dazu geäußert und immer wieder vereinzelt. Aber da fehlen mir die Initiativen. Und auch ein bisschen der Druck darauf.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass diese Steuerthematik, die wir jetzt seit 2016 veröffentlichen und thematisieren, dass das nur die Spitze des Eisbergs ist. Über Steuern erwischt man die meisten Kriminellen. Das ist nicht erst seit LKP und so. Sondern das hat man in ganz vielen der Bereiche der Kriminalität, dass die Finanzämter der Anfang von einem Einblick in schmutzige Geschäfte sind. Ich glaube, dass wir mit den Enthüllungen, die wir jetzt gerade vorantreiben und die in den nächsten Wochen kommen werden, am Ende deutlich über die Steuer hinausgehen werden. In den Bereich Korruption hinein geraten werden. Wie fließen Gelder eigentlich zurück an Staaten? Wie profitieren Staaten von diesem Einfluss auf Vereine? Wie haben Staaten in den letzten Jahrzehnten für sich Programme entwickelt, mit denen sie möglicherweise sogar diese Vereine als reine Geldwaschmaschinen, als reine Profitmaschinen ausnutzen, benutzen? Das werden wir werden uns jetzt in den nächsten Wochen auch mal intensiver mit dem als Monaco beschäftigen, bei dem es einen Oligarchen namens Herrn Rübo Loeffler gibt, der, um ehrlich zu sein, ziemlich spannend ist. Das sind alles Dinge, die peu à peu von uns aufgedeckt werden können. Möglicherweise hast du recht, zu moralisch aufgedeckt werden, weil wir auch oftmals selbst empört sind über all diese Vorgänge. Wir glauben, dass sich Experten, Steuerrichtler, Anwälte, Politiker deutlich intensiver mit all den Enthüllungen beschäftigen müssen. Wir sind am Ende auch nur Journalisten und können die Missstände einer Branche aufzeigen. Wie dann am Ende Politiker und Experten oder auch Justiz und einzelne Branchenmitglieder mit diesen Enthüllungen umgehen. Das liegt ja nicht mehr in unserer Hand, sondern wir versuchen der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen, das ist der Missstand. So daneben liegen die Gesetzmäßigkeiten im Fußball und jetzt dürft ihr euch alle Gedanken darüber machen, wie man das verändert oder ob man das verändern kann.
Das ist der Schritt, der mir manchmal fehlt. Das Moralisierende in eurer Richterstattung haben wir in fast allen Football Leaks-Folgen schon mal angesprochen. Das ist letztlich auch eine Geschmacksfrage. Was eben auffällt, ist, ihr haut schon auf die größtmögliche Pauke moralisch gesehen mit gewissen Formulierungen. Es steht nicht weniger auf dem Spiel als die Zukunft des Fußballs. Das ist dann zum Beispiel ein Beispiel. Oder eben auch, dass der Spiegeltitel mit Verrat überschrieben war. Das hat ja auch schon eine gewisse Tonalität. Und wie gesagt, da könnten wir jetzt auch lange diskutieren. Haben wir aber auch schon mal an dieser Stelle getan. Mir fehlt immer genau dieser eine Schritt noch, dass man nachdem man das alle aufgezeigt hat, dass man dann hingeht zum, warum nicht mal zum Bundesfinanzminister zum Beispiel gehen und sagen, Herr Minister, wie lange wollen Sie eigentlich noch zulassen, dass es hier einen Wirtschaftszweig gibt, der in Deutschland sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient, der sich jeglicher staatlicher Kontrolle entzieht? Das ist so, finde ich, das fehlt mir immer.
Also zum einen ist es schon etwas, was wir ja in der Berichterstattung auch probieren, dass wir an Experten herantreten und mit den Experten darüber sprechen und uns Meinungen dazu einholen. Aber das andere ist in der Tat so, wir sind diejenigen, die enthüllen und wir hoffen, dass es danach auch immer zu diesen Debatten kommt, und dass Kollegen möglicherweise diese Debatten aufnehmen und eben dann den nächsten Schritt tun und O-Töne einholen, Gedanken einholen, die Debatte nach vorne treiben. Das alles von einem Medienhaus zu erwarten und zu fordern oder von einem Recherchenetzwerk zu fordern, ist halt ziemlich viel verlangt. Das können wir nicht leisten.
Klar, aber ihr setzt doch den Ton der Debatte. Ich werde ganz bewusst, wollte ich eigentlich erst am Ende dieser Sendung über die Super League sprechen. Denn das war für mich genau das Beispiel dafür, wie ich zwar verstehen kann, warum ihr mit einem Titel, der sich darauf bezieht, rausgeht, aber wie die Debatte schon in der Sekunde, nachdem das öffentlich wurde, um die völlig falschen Dinge ging. Da wurde dann darüber diskutiert, wie die Super League genau ausgesehen hätte, wie die Gelder verteilt werden. Ist jetzt dann der BVB, kann der absteigen oder kann der nicht absteigen? Das war den Leuten wichtig. Aber es ging nicht darum, was eigentlich das Dahinterstehende ist. Und ich finde schon, dass mit der Art und Weise, wie man die Themen setzt und wie man sie erzählt, könnt ihr ja schon auch da in eine Richtung zeigen. Und dass die anderen Journalisten, klar, dass auch andere Journalisten in einer Verantwortung stehen, völlig klar. Auch ich hier habe mich entschieden, wie ich mit diesem Thema umgehen möchte. Aber ihr könnt das ja schon so in gewisse Bahnen lenken und meinem Gefühl nach entgleiten, diese Debatten ganz schnell, jetzt nach fast allen Veröffentlichungen, ganz schnell in ein Feld, wo die Leute mit den Schultern zucken und sagen, ja, im Grunde wusste man das ja schon so. Und ja, mei, sollen sie halt machen, ich mag die Bayern eh nicht. Und quasi dieser nächste Schritt wird so selten gegangen.
Ich glaube, auch da überschätzt du die Möglichkeiten eines Recherchennetzwerks oder einer Enthüllung. Wir sind natürlich genau mit diesen Titeln, mit der Berichterstattung zum Verrat der Bayern on to Super League, wollten wir ja, der Verrat bezieht sich ja auf ein Verrat gegenüber den mittleren und klaren Verein, das beschreiben wir im Text an zig Stellen, auf 1200 Zeilen, in denen wir immer wieder sagen, da haben die Top Clubs, die Top 7 unter Federführung des FC Bayern, die Interessen von mittleren und kleinen Vereinen verraten. Wir beschreiben, ich glaube von diesen 1200 Zeilen sind 1150 Zeilen in den sportpolitischen Machtkämpfen von Top Clubs hinter dem Rücken der Vereine, der Ligen und Verbände. Das war uns wichtig zu zeigen, wie die, auf welche Art und Weise sie mehr oder minder in einer Kartell-ähnlichen Situation, die die Grundzüge einer Erpressung trug, die UEFA mit dem Rücken zur Wand gestellt haben und dort in der Lage waren, von der UEFA nahezu alles zu fordern, was man nur als Top Club fordern kann, um seine eigene Vormachtstellung zu betonieren. Als wir den Text fertig hatten, sind wir natürlich davon ausgegangen, dass die Debatte genau in die Richtung läuft, dass sich EU-Richtler dazu zu Wort melden und sagen, eine solche Kartellvereinigung, die aus sieben Wettbewerbern besteht, die eigentlich nichts miteinander zu tun haben sollen, die sich aber zusammenschließen, um den bestehenden Wettbewerb auszuhebeln, von dem sie jahrelang sehr gut profitiert haben, also Bundesliga oder die Champions League und Pläne dazu schmieden, auf welche Art und Weise sie miteinander aus diesen Wettbewerben möglicherweise austreten können und eben einen eigenen Wettbewerb dazu gestalten können, den sie auch noch mal untereinander absprechen. Das habe ich eigentlich gedacht, wird der Kern der Diskussion sein, dass man eben darüber spricht, wie diese Machtausnutzung der Top-Klubs, wie die sich eigentlich wirtschaftlich auswirkt und wie sie dann am Ende, wenn man sich das Ergebnis der UEFA-Reform anguckt, wie massiv sie mittlere und kleine Klubs schädigt und ihnen am Ende eben auch einen finanziellen Nachteil auf Sicht zufügt. Auch da müssten normalerweise, hätten aus meiner Sicht, einen Aufschrei erfolgen müssen. Die Vereine, die sich dann eben zu Wort hätten melden müssen und sagen müssen, okay, das war so nicht erkennbar. Es war für uns nicht klar, dass diese Top-Clubs sich im Vorfeld mit der UEFA getroffen haben und für sich haben ausrechnen lassen, wie viele Gewinne sie erreichen werden mit dieser Reform. Wie hoch ihre eigenen Anteile sein werden. Warum durften wir das als FC Augsburg nicht tun oder als Bologna oder Kiewo Werona oder sonst was? Warum ist uns das nicht ermöglicht worden, dass wir auch eine solche Simulation hätten mitmachen dürfen, um zu sehen, ob wir durch diese Reform möglicherweise Nachteile erlangen werden?
Das kann man ja schnell erklären, warum der FC Augsburg da nicht mit am Tisch sitzen durfte. Aber die Frage sollte sein, warum lassen wir uns in der European Club Association von jemanden vertreten, der ganz offensichtlich ein doppeltes Spiel gespielt hat, nämlich Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, der auf der einen Seite in diesem, wie ihr es nennt, Geheimbund solche sehr konkreten Gedankenspiele vorangetrieben hat und auf der anderen Seite stellvertretend für die ganzen Verbände und Vereine gesprochen hat. Das habt ihr ja auch versucht aufzuzeigen, auch deswegen der Verrat. I feel you und ich kann das nachvollziehen. Aber das ist der Kern. Also es wurde danach darüber diskutiert, wie dieser Wettbewerb hätte aussehen sollen und ob es diese Super League nicht sowieso schon irgendwie gibt und ob das nicht vielleicht was Tolles wäre. Und im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, es gibt einen Sammelthread, wo mir Hörerinnen und Hörer zukünftige Themen vorschlagen können. Und natürlich kamen da sehr schnell, hier mach doch bitte wieder was zu Football Leaks. Und dann artete die Diskussion über den Super League so sehr aus, dass ich es auslage, musste einen eigenen Thread, der fröhlich weiter vor sich hin diskutiert wird, wo es nur noch geht um, wäre denn ein salary cap möglich? Wie soll denn das mit Auf- und Abstieg laufen? Warum wäre der BVB erstmal nur Gastverein? Also darüber wurde dann die ganze Zeit diskutiert. Und vielleicht hätte man es dann mehr an der Person von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge zum Beispiel aufhängen sollen. Weil das ist ja das eigentliche. Das ist, als würde dein Betriebsrat mit den Aufsichtsräten am Tisch sitzen und über Lohnkurzungen debattieren dafür, dass er aber ein höheres Weihnachtsgeld bekommt.
Die erste Ausgabe ist ja mit Absicht auch eine Ausgabe, die sich auf der einen Seite mit der Gründung oder mit den Gedankenspielen zur Gründung der Super League auseinandersetzt, gleichzeitig aber zeigt, wie der höchste Funktionär des Fußballs, Gianni Infantino, als damaliger UEFA-Generalsekretär, bestimmte Regularien auseinandersetzt und wie eben diese Investorenclubs diesen Druck auf die UEFA erhöhen. Das heißt, eigentlich war die erste Ausgabe, wenn man sie von Anfang bis zum Ende liest, soll sie eben zeigen, wie von beiden Seiten die UEFA massiv unter Druck gesetzt wird. Von den Traditionsvereinen auf der einen Seite, von den Investorenclubs auf der anderen Seite. Und wie sie in der Mitte eigentlich als Governance-Buddy komplett machtlos ist, wie sie nicht in der Lage ist, das zu steuern, das zu kontrollieren, wie sie nicht in der Lage ist, genau diesen Wettbewerb in Bahnen zu führen, sondern sich eben durchweg über die Leichten ziehen lässt. Durchweg auch die Interessen derjenigen verrät. Deswegen, der Verrat hatte an ganz vielen Stellen in den drei Geschichten spielt eine entscheidende Rolle. Das spielt ja nicht nur bei der FC Bayern eine entscheidende Rolle, das spielt eben bei der UEFA eine entscheidende Rolle, das spielt bei PSG und bei Manchester City eine ganz entscheidende Rolle. Die erste Geschichte beginnt ja auch nicht als reine Geschichte über die Super League, sondern die erste Geschichte ist aufgemacht mit Dirty Deals. Und all die Köpfe, die dort in den Dirty Deals vorhanden sind, sind ja diejenigen, die sich über die nächsten drei Geschichten ziehen und dort miteinander zu tun haben. Das war eigentlich unsere Intention, jetzt kann man sagen, Thema gesetzt und Ziel nicht komplett erreicht, weil das ist in der Auseinandersetzung rund um die Super League untergegangen oder es ist einfach nicht so geführt worden. Ich hoffe oder sehe jetzt ein bisschen Licht am Ende des Tunnels, weil in den letzten Tagen immer mehr Berichte dazu kamen, nachdem jetzt einmal diese ganz große Empörung über die Super League sich etwas gelegt hat, beginnen jetzt kluge Köpfe, sich genau mit diesem Komplex auseinanderzusetzen und zu sehen, wie schwierig und wie aus dem Ruder geraten im Moment die UEFA ist und als Kontrollinstanz für die einzelnen Clubs und wie sehr sich die Clubs mittlerweile selbstständig machen, was am Ende dazu führen kann, dass sie sich in so kleinen Elite-Zirkeln treffen, die die Geldflüsse nicht transparenter, sondern noch intransparenter machen. Denn so kleine Geldflüsse, das haben wir spätestens mit dem WMOK rund um die Umtersommermärchen 2006 gelernt, sind extrem anfällig für dunkle Machenschaften und Geldflüsse, die völlig abseits der Öffentlichkeit ablaufen. Damit möchte ich aber sagen, wir haben schon sehr wohl darauf oder versucht, darauf abzuziehen, dass diese Debatte in diese Richtung geht und dass sie sich damit beschäftigt, welche Regularien in Zukunft erarbeitet werden müssten, wie möglicherweise die strafrechtlichen Konsequenzen von so einer Kartellartigen Zusammenkunft sind, der Fußball sich auch viel stärker mit der Rolle von wirklich top funktionierenden und handelnden Führungspersonen wie Karl-Heinz Rummelige oder Michael Gerlinger oder Gianni Infantino auseinandersetzen, dass diese Personen noch stärker in den Fokus der Debatte geraten. Wir sind teilweise auch etwas erschrocken, wie viele Medien diese Debatte auf die Art und Weise gekillt haben, indem sie sagen, naja, die Super League ist das natürliche Element, was als nächstes kommen soll. Die nicht dahinter sehen und schauen, welche Machenschaften dazu führen, dass wir jetzt an einem Punkt sind, an dem der FC Bayern sechsmal deutscher Meister geworden ist und Juventus Turin siebenmal italienischer Meister. Genau die beiden Clubs, die von Karl-Heinz Rummelige und Herrn Anjeli, den beiden Vorsitzenden der ECA geführt werden. Und die nicht nur in der letzten Rechnerperiode, sondern auch in den Rechnerperioden davor immens für die Rechte der großen und Top-Clubs eingestanden haben. Und am Ende natürlich auch für ihre eigenen.
Ja, also den Teil der Medienkritik finde ich, den kann man so unwidersprochen stehen lassen. Die Auseinandersetzung mit euren Recherchergebnissen erfolgt auch manchmal auf einer oberflächlichen und manchmal einer fast zynischen, das ist sowieso ein Problem des Sportjournalismus, des Zynismus-Ebene.
Ich möchte gar keine Medienbashing machen.
Bashing sollte es auch nicht sein.
Ich schätze nahezu alle Kollegen, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten. Ich würde mir einfach schlicht und ergreifend manchmal wünschen, dass man weniger auf uns abzielt als auf den Kern der Geschichten. Das ist immer so ein bisschen Nase rümpfen und okay, jetzt haben die da eine Geschichte gemacht. Mal gucken, was draus wird, statt dass man sich mit den Inhalten beschäftigt. Wenn wir so eine Geschichte am Freitagabend um 18 Uhr bringen, und ich bekomme die ersten Interviewanfragen um 18.15 oder 18.20 Uhr, in denen mich Kollegen fragen, ob ich eine Einordnung der Super League machen kann, dann stehe ich ganz oft am Telefon und denke mir, ihr hattet noch gar nicht die Möglichkeit, den Artikel in der Kürze der Zeit gelesen zu haben. Welche Fragen wollt ihr mir denn dazu stellen, die tatsächlich in die Tiefe gehen und sich mit dem beschäftigen, was ich eigentlich damit aussagen möchte oder welche Diskussion ich damit anregen möchte? Das sind dann vielleicht so die Momente, in denen ich am meisten die Hände über den Kopf schlage. Denn unser Ziel ist es schon, dass wir nicht nur enthöhnen und für eine kurzzeitige Empörung sorgen, sondern dass wir am Ende für eine Debatte sorgen, die nicht nur bei den kritischen Fans ankommt, sondern die am Ende selbstverständlich auch im Sportjournalismus, in der Politik, möglicherweise auch in der Justiz geführt wird. Das ist doch das, worauf wir hinaus wollen. Komischerweise funktioniert das auch in der Wirtschaft. Wenn wir uns die Panama Papers oder Paradise Papers angucken, funktioniert das dort sehr wohl. Journalisten setzen sich mit diesen Themen sehr stark auseinander. Wirtschaftsjournalisten, politische Journalisten, Berichterstatter setzen sich damit auseinander. Im Sportjournalismus, am Ende, sitze ich in Talkshows und werde gefragt, wo ist denn eigentlich das Problem, wenn sich dann ein Kartell gründet? Und dann sitzt du da und dir fällt alles aus dem Gesicht. Wenn du da anfangen musst, dieses Problem nochmal zu erklären, dann musst du halt sehr, sehr früh anfangen.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man aus einer Sicht des Unbedarfen, in Anführungszeichen nicht negativ gemeint, Zuschauers fragt, dann ist ja so eine Frage auch in Ordnung, um nochmal die Grundzüge darzustellen. Aber ich wollte auch kein Bashing betreiben, aber ein Teil dieser Football Leaks hat immer auch mit der Weiterverarbeitung in Medien zu tun und Fragen, die sich stellen, warum das manchmal auf die eine und auf die andere Art und Weise passiert.
Und da ist es auch spannend, wir sehen ja, wie sich die englischen Kollegen im Moment mit Manchester City auseinander sitzen. Wie sie tatsächlich die einzelnen FFP-Regularien sezieren.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen, ja.
Also wenn du dir den Guardian anguckst, das sind brillante Texte, die sich damit beschäftigen. Die New York Times hat jetzt ein, die haben als einziges wirklich so ein richtiges Übersichtsstück gebracht. Von Super League bis Financial Fair Play mit Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, mit Gianni Infantino, mit Gerlinger. Die haben genau diesen Bogen, waren in der Lage, diesen Bogen zu spannen, den wir eigentlich in der Debatte so dringend gesucht haben. Wir haben gestern ein Ask Me Anything bei Reddit gemacht, bei dem wir so tolle Fragen bekommen haben.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Besser als in vielen Talkshows.
Ja, verdammt und dann sitzt du da und denkst dir, ja genau, genau das ist die Debatte, die ich haben wollte. Genau darüber will ich doch mit euch reden. Ich möchte nicht mit euch darüber reden, ob die Super League jetzt 16 oder 18 Klubs haben wird. Ich will nicht mit euch darüber reden, ob Hans-Joachim Watzke jetzt ein Bekenntnis zur Bundesliga abgibt oder nicht. Weil das ist alles unerheblich. Das ist nicht das, was der Kern der Berichterstattung sein soll, sondern der Kern der Berichterstattung soll sein, wie Sportpolitik in der Lage ist, am Ende den Wettbewerb, den alle, die den Fußball lieben, vollkommen zerstört hat in den letzten Jahren. Und zwar auf eine Art und Weise mit Machtziekel, die sich etabliert haben in den letzten 20 Jahren bedingt durch das TV-Geld, das reingekommen ist, die völlig überholt sind. Und die Personen, die dort als handelnde Personen tätig sind, sind diejenigen, die dieses System über Jahre mit aufgebaut und gefüttert haben. Und über diese Personen zu sprechen und daraus eine Systemdiskussion zu machen, das ist doch eigentlich das, worauf es am Ende hinauslaufen sollte. Und das ist das, was mir tatsächlich fehlt, wenn ich nicht im Rasenfunk sitze.
Ja gut, danke, jetzt schmeichelst du mir natürlich auch. Und speichern wir es mal unter Höflichkeit ab. Aber das ist auch ein Punkt, den ich ansprechen wollte. Das ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, dass ihr, ich würde den Startpunkt so sanft setzen bei rund um Christiano Ronaldo und die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe ihm gegenüber, auf öffentlicheren Plattformen in die Diskussion gegangen seid. Also zum einen über Twitter, zum Beispiel hat da Christoph Winterbach lange Threads angefertigt, die ja dann auch zu großen Reichweiten und Diskussionen geführt haben. Und eben dieses Ask Me Anything, was ihr gestern Abend am Montagabend bei Reddit gemacht habt, was ich auch mit großem Interesse gelesen habe. Ist das jetzt Zufall oder hängt das vielleicht mit den Dingen zusammen, die wir vorher besprochen haben, dass ihr jetzt vielleicht euch auch ein bisschen für Diskussionen öffnen müsst, für auch andere Diskussionsteilnehmer als in Anführungszeichen nur Journalisten?
Als wir 2016 mit dem European Investigative Collaborations, mit dem EIC, gemeinsam an Football Leaks gearbeitet haben, hatten wir de facto noch nichts. Wir haben uns einen Datenraum selbst erschaffen müssen. Wir haben uns die Software besorgen und auch aneignen müssen. Wir mussten den Umgang mit über 12 Medienhäusern, jetzt sind es über 15 Medienhäusern, lernen. Wir mussten kapieren, wie wir auf solchen Plattformen miteinander kommunizieren. All das hat, um ehrlich zu sein, extrem viel an Kraft gekostet. Und wenn man dann die Enthüllung an die Öffentlichkeit bringt, ist es aus alter Tradition von Enthüllern ja auch eher so, man bringt die Enthüllung und guckt dann, was die Gesellschaft daraus macht. Für das zweite Projekt konnten wir viele Körner im Vorfeld ja schon einsparen, indem wir auf bestehende Systeme zurückgreifen können, wie zum Beispiel den Datenraum, die Software, das Team, den Umgang mit den Kollegen, unsere verschlüsselte Kommunikation. Das steht alles, darauf konnten wir zurückgreifen und haben jetzt auch vielleicht etwas mehr Raum, etwas mehr Möglichkeiten, auch etwas mehr Kraft, um danach in der zweiten Etappe uns mit weiteren Diskussionen auseinanderzusetzen. Christoph Winterbach ist für uns da eine echte Perle, weil er ein ganz tolles Händchen dafür hat, wie öffentliche Diskussionen im Internet geführt werden. Sei es durch einen Threat, den er damals gemacht hat, der wirklich auch in Amerika total durch die Decke gegangen ist, weil er sich getraut hat, viele Einblicke in unsere Arbeit zu geben. Auch das ist ja etwas, was in der Kultur von Enthüllern nicht unbedingt verankert ist. Normalerweise reden wir nicht über Quellen, wir zeigen nicht Originaldokumente. All das sind Dinge, die einen am Ende auch auf die Füße fallen können, weil sie immer auch die Quelle gefährden. Und das ist eine wahnsinnige Abwägungsfrage, ob man diese Sachen der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen möchte oder nicht. Wir beraten dann auch ewig, welche Dokumente können wir zeigen? Wie müssen wir die Dokumente auch präsentieren, damit man sie versteht? Weil sie sonst möglicherweise aus dem Zusammenhang von Dutzenden anderen Dokumenten herausgerissen werden. Und da ist Christoph schon jemand, der sich extrem viele Gedanken dazu macht. Ich fand das Ammer gestern ziemlich spannend. Das war auch Christophs Idee, dass wir dort reingehen. Ich glaube auch da, dass wir auch Sicht dort noch besser werden können, weil auch da kann man mit Dokumenten agieren, auch da kann man mit mehr Unterfütterung der eigenen Diskussionsebene agieren. Aber das sind Schritte, da muss ich persönlich auch ein bisschen um Nachsicht der Öffentlichkeit bitten. Da sind wir ja auch in einem totalen Lernprozess.
Das ist ja auch euer erstes Football Leaks.
Ja, wir fühlen uns ja hier, obwohl der Spiegel 72 Jahre alt ist, fühlen wir uns ja so ein bisschen wie in einem Start-up, wenn wir dieses Projekt machen, weil wir ganz viele der früheren Gegebenheiten und auch der Regeln des Hauses strapazieren, an Grenzen bringen, manchmal auch ad absurdum führen, weil sie eben nicht übertragbar sind auf das, was wir jetzt aktuell machen. Und diese Auseinandersetzung mit uns selbst, mit uns als investigative Einheit, aber auch mit der Öffentlichkeit, die dauern an. Wir lernen daraus, wir führen Tagebücher, was während dieser Projekte gut läuft und was nicht so gut läuft. Und überlegen uns, wie wir das fürs nächste Mal noch besser machen. Und ich kann jetzt schon sagen, dass wir bislang sehr viel daraus gelernt haben, dass das Führen von öffentlichen Diskussionen für uns als investigative nicht mehr zu vermeiden ist. Wir müssen das machen, weil wir eben dadurch Einblicke geben, Erklärungen liefern und auch ein bisschen den Rahmen für die Diskussion vielleicht stärker vorgeben als nur durch 23 Seiten Text, den wir veröffentlichen. Aber auch da sage ich dir, da verändert sich natürlich dann auch die Arbeitsweise eines Journalisten.
Klar, du sprichst jetzt mit mir und machst nicht die nächste Football Leaks-Veröffentlichung. Genau.
Der Arbeitsalltag hat 24 Stunden. Wir arbeiten die letzten Monate, ich würde sagen, es ist kaum jemand unter 16 Stunden aus dem Haus gegangen. Das sind auch alles Dinge, die nur über eine gewisse Weile möglich sind. Na klar, kann man dann sagen, dann müsst ihr euer Team größer machen und ihr müsst noch mehr Leute mit reinnehmen. Aber auch da ist dann kosten- und nutzend eine Frage, wie viele Leute kann man wirklich für solche Recherchen abstellen, wenn wir jetzt schon über 100 sind und wir haben aber einen Datensatz, der auch jetzt, obwohl wir 70 Millionen Dokumente vorliegen haben, auch jetzt noch nicht ansatzweise auserzählt ist. Wir sitzen jetzt wieder in den Daten und arbeiten quasi an den Daten jetzt schon wieder weiter. Weil wir viele der Geschichten oder weil wir uns während wir uns auf Geschichten geeinigt haben, noch weitere Geschichten rausgeschrieben haben, die wir jetzt in den nächsten Monaten machen werden. Also all das sind ja auch Belastungen, auch private Belastungen, die dazukommen, körperliche Belastungen, die dazukommen, die man oftmals nicht sieht, wenn man einfach nur darüber spricht, warum habt ihr noch nicht das gemacht, warum habt ihr nicht noch das gemacht, warum habt ihr nicht noch das gemacht. Weil einfach die Zeit und auch die Ressourcen manchmal nicht so dafür da sind, und man sich schlicht und ergreifend bestimmte Dinge reduzieren, fokussieren muss.
Eine Sache würde ich gerne herausgreifen, weil du auch vorhin davon gesprochen hast, wie viel ihr abwägen müsst, um auch die Quelle, John und alles, was dahinter steht, zu schützen. Und da hätte ich eine Frage zu der Doku, die es gab im ersten. Das ist, wo man dich begleiten konnte, unter anderem, also es war ein Teil dieser Doku, aber auch übrigens der ja am meisten zitierte Teil, und auch auf dem Spiegel konnte man da Aussagen von dir sehen. Man konnte dir dabei zusehen, wie du dich mit John trist, und tatsächlich gab es dann auch ein Video, das John zeigt, vermummt und so weiter, aber man könnte zum Beispiel aus dem Video rauslesen, dass er Rechtshänder ist, weil er mit der rechten Hand die USB-Festplatte anschließt. Es gibt über Frequenzschwankungen in Stromnetzen, kann man manchmal über Videoaufnahmen auch einen Ort herausfinden. Ich habe mich gefragt, warum musste es sein, dass man dich auf dem Weg zu John sieht und dass man dann am Ende auch die Quelle selbst sieht? Welchen Mehrwert hat das, wenn er sich ja eh komplett vermummt und nicht spricht?
Ich habe das mit ziemlich vielen Bauchschmerzen gemacht. Ich habe das mit ihm im Vorfeld abgesprochen. Für den Film war es, ich bin kein Filmmacher, aber für den Film war es offenbar wichtig, einen roten Faden zu haben. Und der rote Faden war ich bzw. war John, der durch die sehr komplexen Geschichten führt. Das konnte ich ab einer gewissen Grenze oder einer gewissen Ebene nachvollziehen. Wir haben im Übrigen das gleiche Stilmittel für das Buch benutzt. Das Buch hat John als verbindendes Element zwischen den großen Enthüllungen. Das funktioniert sehr gut, weil man auf der einen Seite vielleicht komplexe Dinge erklären kann und gleichzeitig einen Krimi erzählen kann. Und so ist die Übertragung auf dem Film auf die Art und Weise auch stattgefunden. Ich selbst hätte es weder gebraucht, mich dort zu zeigen als Person, weil das auch mich gefährdet. Aber ich hätte es schon gar nicht gebraucht, ihn zu zeigen. Ich konnte aber nachvollziehen, dass die Regisseurinnen bzw. Regisseure, die den Film gemacht haben, auch für ihr Transparenzgefühl gesagt haben, wir müssen sehen, dass es noch eine zweite Person neben dir gibt. Und du am Ende nicht du derjenige bist, der dieses Zeug beschafft. Sondern dass es wirklich jemanden gibt, der das tut. Und du mit ihm in einem Raum bist. Auch das sind ja Elemente, die aus journalistischer Sicht für mich nachvollziehbar sind. Das war der Punkt, an dem sie mich auch bekommen haben. Weil wenn ich jetzt einsteigen würde in ein solches Projekt und einer erzählt mir, ja ja, ich habe da einen Whistleblower und der Whistleblower gibt uns irgendwelche Festplatten. Aber man selbst nie Zugang dazu hat, wäre ich sehr lange sehr skeptisch gewesen. Und so hatten auch die Filmemacher zumindest die Möglichkeit, in einer winzigen Sequenz zu sehen, da ist jemand, der uns diese Daten zur Verfügung stellt. Aber ansonsten wird von seiner Identität nichts preisgegeben. Das war ein Deal, den John auch nachvollziehen konnte.
Es ist eine interessante Debatte, auch weil es so ein Metathema ist, aber auch so ein bisschen eine Journalistendebatte. Ich verweise dazu auch nur auf einen Übermedienartikel, den ich verlinken werde in den Show Notes, rund um die Cum-Ex-Betrugsfälle gab es ein Panoramabeitrag. Die Überschrift ist ein bisschen anonym, wie Selfie, Journalismus, Informanten gefährdet. Das ist quasi die Metadebatte, die über so etwas steht. Wir haben ja auch schon häufiger darüber gesprochen. Der verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit Whistleblowern ist eines der wichtigsten Themen bei Football Leaks. Und in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich mit dir auch noch über ein anderes Thema sprechen, nämlich einen Bericht eines portugiesischen Nachrichtenmagazins namens Sabado. Das glaubt zu wissen, wer Don sei, nämlich ein portugiesischer Student, der in Geschichte seinen Abschluss gemacht hat und später dann für ein Informatikstudium Portugal verlassen hat. Warum habe ich dazu im Spiegel und auf spiegel.de nichts gelesen?
Zum einen, weil es mich extrem befremdet, dass der gesamte Name einer Person irgendwo genannt wird, ohne dass diese Person sich dazu äußert, dass sie etwas dazu sagt.
Wobei er später dann mit Journalisten gesprochen hat. Das stimmt. Aber in der Ursprungsveröffentlichung wurde quasi nur über ihn berichtet und nicht mit ihm.
Das andere ist, ich glaube, das ist der achte Satz in dem Artikel, den ich auch gelesen habe, in dem steht, es gibt für all das keine Belege. Das steht drin, dass es offenbar ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen eine Person gibt und dass diese Person möglicherweise etwas zu tun hat mit Football Leaks. Ich habe da keinerlei weitere oder fortführende Beweise zu gelesen oder Belege zu gelesen. Dementsprechend muss ich immer sagen, ich äußere mich nicht zu diesen Artikeln oder ich als Rechercheur werde nichts zu solchen Artikeln sagen. Weder kann ich sagen, ob er es ist, oder sagen, dass er es nicht ist, weil wenn ich damit anfange, komme ich ein totales Quellen-Bingo. Und wenn es dann irgendwann tatsächlich so sein sollte, dass da meine Quelle im Bild oder sonst was genannt wird und mich jemand fragt, dann kann ich mich eben nicht auf den Punkt zurückziehen, an den ich mich jetzt zurückziehen kann und sagen kann, dazu sage ich nichts. Aber dass du davon nichts im Spiegel gelesen hast, ist nicht richtig, weil in der Super League-Geschichte habe ich ein langes Kapitel über John, bei dem ich auf Medienberichterstattung, es war ja nicht nur Sabado, sondern es war die Medienberichterstattung in Portugal eingehe und dort eben beschreibe, dass es zahlreiche Vorwürfe gibt, mit denen ich John konfrontiere. Da geht es ja insbesondere um die Benfica-Lisabon-Berichterstattung, weil es dort in Portugal ein League gab, das nachweislich zeigt, dass Benfica-Lisabon, sagen wir es jetzt mal vorsichtig, aber in extreme Grenzbereiche der Legalität vorgeschlossen ist. Damit ist Korruption gemeint, damit ist Spielmanipulation gemeint, damit ist der nicht angemessene Umgang mit Schiedsrichtern gemeint. All das ist durch ein League in Portugal entstanden, was nicht als Football Leaks gelaufen, sondern ein Benfica League war. Und damit habe ich John konfrontiert. Er bestreitet, dass er derjenige war, der dieses League in Portugal ausgelöst hat. Er bestreitet nach wie vor, dass er ein Hacker ist. Er bestreitet, dass die Daten geklaut sind. Am Ende kann man das glauben oder man kann es sein lassen. Genauso schreibe ich es auch in dem und sage, wir können uns immer nur auf die rechtliche Position in Deutschland zurückziehen und sagen, weder haben wir jemanden gehackt, noch lassen wir irgendjemanden hacken, sondern wir sind diejenigen, die von einem Whistleblower Dokumente entgegennehmen, der sich als Whistleblower ausgibt, diese Dokumente oder der sich bezeichnet als Whistleblower. Wir können seinen Hintergrund nicht weitergehend prüfen. Offenbar kann es aber auch die Justiz nicht, denn sonst würde er nicht seit drei Jahren auf freiem Fuß sein. Wir können uns auf den Punkt zurückziehen, dass wir die Berichterstattung weiter fortführen können, weil wir mit Material arbeiten, das für die Öffentlichkeit relevant und authentisch ist. Dann ist der Ursprung, woher es kommt, für das deutsche Medienrecht uninteressant.
Das haben wir auch schon länger diskutiert. Die Diskussion hatten wir schon. Das stimmt natürlich, du hast es in dem aktuellen Aufmacher-Artikel gesagt. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass es damals, Mitte September, in der Süddeutschen ein größeres Stück dazu gab. Ansonsten habe ich im deutschsprachigen Journalismus fast nichts gefunden. Es war für mich fast unmöglich, jetzt noch mal alle Sachen nachzurecherchieren. Interessanterweise haben die UK-Kollegen an der Stelle wieder viel genauer. Die haben dann auch Pinto ausfindig gemacht, gibt da ein gutes Stück bei der Daily Mail. Das werde ich verlinken. Rui Pinto ist ein interessanter Fall. Da gibt es verschiedene Indizien, die darauf hinweisen, dass es da zumindest einen Bezug zu Football Leaks-Dingen gibt, unter anderem über einen Anwalt, der auch in Football Leaks-Dingen zu sprechen kommt. Ich will aber eigentlich bei dieser Jagd nach John gar nicht mitmachen, denn das finde ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt wenig relevant für die Öffentlichkeit, außer dass natürlich wir alle uns ein Interview von ihm angucken würden. Das ist halt der Edward Snowden-Effekt. Edward Snowden war toll dann zu sehen, wer dahinter steckt, warum er das gemacht hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber für die Debatte hat das eigentlich nichts zu tun. Deswegen will ich damit nichts mitmachen. Aber ich finde, da hängt ein zweiter Themenkomplex dran. Und das ist die Frage, auf die er auch immer wieder eingeht. Wie sauber ist Football Leaks? Aus welchen Quellen kommen diese Dinge? Wenn wir Chatverläufe haben, wenn wir zum Beispiel sehen, dass diese Europa League-Geschichte, Super Europa League, also die ESL-Geschichte, immer noch unfassbar, dass die sich so nennen wollen wie die ESL. Aber gut, ist halt der Fußball eher so arrogant zu glauben, dass er mit E-Sports nichts zu tun haben muss. Wahnsinn. Aber die war ja hochaktuell, unter anderem deshalb, weil es eine abgefangene E-Mail gab oder eine irgendwie entdeckte E-Mail, die im November 2018 zu einer Absichtserklärung führen hätte können oder vielleicht auch noch führen wird, wo sich eben dann die Vereine darauf verständigt hätten, wir machen das ganz konkret. Das war ja das, was so richtig der Zunder auf dieser Geschichte war, dass das nicht nur irgendwelche Gedankenspiele waren, sondern dass es eben diese E-Mail gab. Und wenn ich mir dann aber angucke, welche Quellen alle zur Verfügung liegen, da haben wir eben E-Mails, wir haben aber auch Chat-Verläufe, wir haben SMS-Verläufe. Ich finde, das ist etwas, über das Football Leaks immer angreifbar sein wird, dass man sagen kann, wie ist es da dran gekommen? Und dann ist auch eine Aussage, wir hacken nicht. Ich hoffe, du hast mal die Gegenfrage gestellt, aber habt ihr denn mal ein Passwort abgefangen oder etwas Ähnliches? Also beim DFB waren wohl offenbar, gab es einen, wie auch immer gearteten Angriff im August. Die FIFA wurde gehackt und dann ist die Frage, ob jemand ein Hacker ist, so ein bisschen auch eine Definitionssache. Hacker ist jemand, der Sicherheitssystem umgeht, um reinzukommen. Ist jemand, der zum Beispiel am Telefon sagt, hallo, ich bin die IT, gib mir mal kurz dein Passwort, ich muss da was ändern, der dann reinkommt, ist der noch ein Hacker?
Also klar, die Frage habe ich selbstverständlich gestellt. Auf die Frage habe ich genau die gleiche Antwort bekommen. John verweist immer wieder auf die Plattform WikiLeaks, bei der es Dutzende Dokumente gab und nie die Frage gestellt wurde, wie die Herkunft der Dokumente ist. Also nie, es ist nie Julian Assange vorgeworfen worden, dass er hacken würde. Man kann das glauben, man kann das lassen. Wir mit unseren Möglichkeiten haben, wir können das nicht ausfindig machen. Wir können uns die Dokumente ansehen. Wir können sehen, dass die Dokumente nicht fremdgesteuert sind. Also dass es nicht ein Angriff auf Real Madrid ist oder ein Angriff auf Bayern München oder ein Angriff auf den DFB, sondern dass nahezu jeder aus der Fußballbranche irgendwie eine Rolle in diesen Dokumenten spielt. Wir haben keine Data und Metadaten dieser Dokumente, die wir sehen könnten, woher sie am Ende tatsächlich stammen. Wir haben die Docs und können die Plausibilität der Docs checken. Und da war es halt durchweg so, dass die Plausibilität für uns niemals Anlass gegeben hat, um einen Zweifel an den Dokumenten herzustellen. Und dass diese Debatte geführt wird, das müssen wir im Prinzip dann auch hinnehmen und diese Debatte auch so führen lassen. Es bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Irgendwann wird man sehen, wie der Hintergrund dieser Dokumente ist. Wir können als Journalisten ja immer wieder nur sagen, wir befinden uns auf rechtlich einwandfreien Boden, in dem wir mit diesen Dokumenten arbeiten. Wenn du diese Frage überträgst auf die Frage, wo beispielsweise die Panama Papers herkommen oder die Paradise Papers herkommen oder Offshore Leaks herkommen, das ist eine ganz wichtige Enthüllung der letzten Jahre, wirst du ja diese Debatte immer wieder auch führen. Du wirst immer wieder an die Frage kommen, wie kann es sein, dass solche Datenberge am Ende irgendwie bei Journalisten aufschlagen.
Aber warum wird es denn hier bei den Football Leaks diese Debatte so sehr anders geführt, als eben zum Beispiel bei den Panama Papers? Liegt es vielleicht daran, weil ihr euch dazu entschieden habt, mit John eine Figur aufzumachen, die es ja gibt, aber die ja stellvertretend zu sein scheint, zumindest für ein größeres Netzwerk?
Da spricht man nicht darüber. Ich kann am Ende sogar noch sagen, ich habe einen leibhaftigen Menschen kennengelernt und konnte mit ihm reden, konnte mit ihm diskutieren, konnte prüfen, wie seine Geisteshaltung zu all den Dingen ist und ob er verlässlich ist in dem, wie er sich verhält oder nicht.
Aber woran liegt es denn dann, dass wir hier bei den Football Leaks so viel über solche Themen diskutieren, die ich damit nicht marginalisieren will, aber es stimmt ja, wenn du sagst, wir führen hier eine Diskussion, die bei anderen Vergleichbarenfällen nicht geführt wird.
Möglicherweise ist es, also man muss ja die Frage stellen, von wem wird sie geführt. Sie wird natürlich in erster Linie von Medien geführt. Wenn die Süddeutsche Zeitung den Sabado-Artikel aufnimmt und ihn in der Größenordnung zeigt, aber dort ebenfalls den Satz zitiert, dass es für all das keine Belege gibt und dass man all das nicht beweisen kann, dann bin ich ehrlicherweise auch ein bisschen erschrocken über die Qualität, mit der wir uns mit solchen Themen beschäftigen. Gerade die Süddeutsche Zeitung, die sich dann auch hinstellt und sagt, wir versuchen, einen maximalen Quellenschutz zu garantieren und wir sind das Haus, das mit den Leaks gearbeitet hat. Und dann aber diese Debatte genau in diese Richtung führt, jetzt noch mal unabhängig davon, ob es die Quelle ist oder nicht, was ja eigentlich noch viel schlimmer ist. Auch nach dem Artikel, den man noch nicht weiß. Ich finde das grenzwertig, ich finde das schwierig. Es ist eine Diskussion, die mich aber auch nicht umtreibt, weil ich mich mit der Person des Whistleblowers nur soweit beschäftige, soweit ich das mit mir selbst vereinbaren kann und soweit ich das auch mit John besprechen kann. Ich habe immer gesagt, dass ich das über John schreibe, worüber ich mit ihm im Vorfeld auch spreche und ihm sage, dass ich finde, dass das und das wichtig ist, dass das veröffentlicht werden sollte und das dann auch tue, wenn er sagt, das ist in Ordnung. Das ist für mich eine Form des Quellenschutzes, die ich nicht in jedem Alltag machen würde. Aber hier versuche ich, maximal natürlich eine Person zu schützen, die jetzt über Jahre immense Risiken auf sich nimmt. Davon nichts im Prinzip privat hat, sondern einfach möchte, dass eine Branche, die aus seiner Sicht echte Probleme hat, wieder sauberer wird. Und dass die Person versuche ich zu schützen, so gut es geht.
Okay, lass uns noch kurz am Schluss, weil wir haben ja auch schon gelernt, deine Zeit ist natürlich sehr beschränkt, sogar für den Rasenfunk. Zwei Themen würde ich gerne kurz noch mit dir besprechen. Zum einen noch mal zurückkommen zu Gianni Infantino und seinen Bezug zu Geld. Wir haben jetzt über seine Zeit als UEFA-Generalsekretär gesprochen und in seiner Stellungnahme hatte er auch unter anderem diesen wunderbaren Satz gesagt, dass alles Dinge, die nichts mit der FIFA zu tun haben. Warum nerven Sie mich damit? Ich bin ja jetzt FIFA-Präsident. Okay, nehmen wir ihn beim Wort und gucken, was er als FIFA-Präsident gemacht hat. Auch da war Geld das wichtigste Thema für ihn, denn er hat den Verbänden der FIFA, die ihn zum Präsidenten gewählt haben, viel davon versprochen. Allein 1,4 Milliarden US-Dollar bei seiner Wahl zum Präsidenten. Da gab es dann noch so eine kleine Nebengeschichte. Ganz interessant, weil die FIFA-Verwaltung aber genauer hingeschaut hat und mehr Fragen bei der Verteilung stellte, kam bei vielen Verbänden fast gar nichts an. Und erst 2017 wurden da die Schleusen geöffnet und seitdem wird das Geld offenbar, nachdem was man jetzt dann bei euch nachlesen konnte, wieder, ich sage mal, mit offenen Händen verteilt und dabei die Augen geschlossen. Wer auf der einen Seite aber viel Geld ausgibt, der muss ja auf der anderen Seite neue Einkünfte haben. Und hier kommt jetzt das Projekt Trophy mit ins Spiel. Kannst du uns kurz sagen, worum geht es dabei? Und vor allem interessiert mich die Frage, kann das Konsequenzen für Gianni Infantino haben, was ihr da aufdecken konntet?
Oder organisiert werden soll, der der FIFA 25 Milliarden Einkommen verspricht. Wenn wir uns auf der einen Seite mit der Super League beschäftigen und mit den Ideen einer Gründung der Super League, dann beschäftigt man sich auf der anderen Seite natürlich damit, wie Gianni Infantino versucht, die Macht über die Clubs zurückzuerlangen. Und zwar weggehend von der UEFA, indem er ihnen eine Weltliga offeriert, mit der sie extrem viel Geld, also 150 Millionen plus pro Verein, für eine Art Sommerturnier einnehmen können. Und dadurch versucht natürlich, diese Vereine auch in den großen Verbänden zu behalten. Gianni Infantino, wenn wir uns die Berichterstattung ansehen, auch sein Eingreifen in den Ethicode, bei dem er den Begriff Korruption ausradiert hat, ich fand die Aussagen vom ehemaligen, oder vom Richter Eckart dazu sehr humorig, der gesagt hat, Gianni Infantino ist mit den Worten angetreten, Korruption aus der Vielfalt zu entfernen. Das hat er geschafft, das Wort taucht dem Ethicode nicht mehr auf. Er hat es radiert. Man kann sehen, wie er mit Mitarbeitern, also aus den Dokumenten kann man sehen, wie er mit Mitarbeitern umgeht, wie er Mitarbeiter auch als Handpuppen benutzt, wie er seine Machtposition stärkt, indem er Mitarbeiter dazu bringt, diese Gelder aus den Sozialpaketen zu verteilen. Das ist ja nichts anderes als das, was Joseph Blatter früher gemacht hat mit Geldverteilungen, um seine eigene Macht zu zementieren. Nur eben diesmal zumindest unter dem Deckmantel der Öffentlichkeit, wobei wir sehen ja, dass die Geldflüsse auch abseits der internationalen Gesetze und Regularien ablaufen, um bestimmte Gelder in bestimmte Länder zu bringen und diese Länder dann weiterhin auch mit Gianni Infantino sympathisieren zu lassen, weil sie eben von der FIFA profitieren. Im Gegenteil ist es so, dass man bei Gianni Infantino sehen kann, und zwar beginnt mit den, wenn ich da den Kant machen kann, beginnt mit den Einmischungen in das Financial Fair Play bis eben heute zum Eingreifen in den Ethic Code, zum Umgang mit den Mitarbeitern, zu seinen völlig intransparenten Ideen des Project Trophies. Im Übrigen sollte der Trust in einer Steueroase in Jersey aufgelegt werden, das also nur zu seiner Transparenz und zu seinem Fingerspitzengefühl gegenüber den aktuellen Debatten. Man muss am Ende sagen, dass dieser Mensch nach all dem, was wir gelesen haben, charakterlich und von der Persönlichkeit her vollkommen fehl am Platz ist, an der Stelle als führende Person eines Verbandes, der nicht nur rechtliche, sondern auch moralische und ethische Ebenen dieses Sportes erfüllen soll und als Instanz für alle anderen stehen soll. Das bildet Gianni Infantino aus unserer Sicht an keiner Stelle ab. Ganz im Gegenteil, er ist im Prinzip das Fleisch von Fleisch in der Lage, all die Deals, die im Fußball ablaufen, auf genau die Art und Weise mitzugehen, auch um seine eigene Machtposition nach wie vor zu stellen.
Und dann kommt man, das scheint einen noch weniger zu überraschen, ein bisschen hat man da eben auch ein Zapplatter-Dijavu und das führt dann eben jenseits von dieser einen Person zu der Frage, was für Veränderungen müssten denn eigentlich her, dass man verhindern kann, dass ein Präsident dem so etwas nachgewiesen werden kann. Offenbar ja mit sehr glaubwürdigen Quellen und so wirklich richtig hat er sich dagegen auch nicht gewehrt. Es ist interessant, welche Argumentationsstrategie er da erfährt. Wie kann man sich dagegen eigentlich als Verband wehren? Was gibt es da sowohl für juristische Möglichkeiten als auch eben wie könnte jetzt zum Beispiel der DFB, der ja auch in bestimmten Gremien mitsitzt, da agieren und das ist jetzt losgelöst von der Person Infantino, die man mögen kann, aber nicht mögen muss und wahrscheinlich weniger mag nach diesen Veröffentlichungen ja die eigentliche Frage.
Also zunächst einmal zum Dementieren. Ich habe sowohl von Gianni Infantino als auch von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge gelernt, dass es sehr einfach ist im Fußball etwas zu dementieren. Und zwar man dementiert einfach etwas, was einem gar nicht vorgeworfen wurde. Und dadurch hat man ein Statement, das um die ganze Welt geht. Das ist eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Stimmung oder das Bild rund um eine Enthüllung zu negieren.
Ihr müsstet halt einfach in Zukunft in Instagram-Stories eure Enthüllungen machen über irgendwelche Spielerfrauen-Accounts. Und dann wird das unwidersprochen einfach so zitiert. Und dann könnt ihr nämlich die genaue Wortwahl diktieren.
Aber auch das ist Wahnsinn. Also wenn wir über Standards reden und über die Möglichkeiten, wie Journalismus eigentlich abbildet, ist das natürlich etwas, woran aber auch schon ganz andere Rechercheure wie Jens Weinreich oft in den letzten Jahren verzweifelt sind und das Gefühl hatten, hier hat man harte Dokumente, man kann etwas offenlegen und auf der anderen Seite sagt einfach etwas und es geht über alle Agenturen in die ganze Welt. Und man fragt sich, warum zur Hölle durfte der das denn jetzt sagen? Das hat ihm niemand vorgeworfen.
Beziehungsweise, warum wurde es nicht in Kontext gesetzt? Es ist ja völlig richtig journalistischer Grundsatz, alle Seiten zu Wort kommen zu lassen, aber den Kontext kann man ja liefern.
Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass selbstverständlich jetzt eigentlich Ermittlungen gegen Gianni Infantino und gegen sein Eingreifen sowohl in den Ethikkodex als auch in die Settlements rund um das Financial Fair Play als auch in die Einsetzung von Frau Rojas eigentlich stattfinden müssten. Reinhard Grinde als Mitglied des UEFA Exkurs hat ja schon angekündigt, dass die UEFA sich mit den Machenschaften von Herrn Infantino beschäftigen will und wird. Ich persönlich bin da sehr skeptisch, ob dabei irgendetwas Ernsthaftes rumkommen wird. Das sind ja nicht Untersuchungsausschüsse, wie man sie im Bundestag kennt oder im EU-Parlament, wo jemand dann auch wirklich gegrillt wird und Dokumente vorgehalten werden, sondern das wird in deutlich geringerem Umfang und Zirkeln versucht zu erraten. Da muss man dann mal sehen, ob wirklich etwas dabei rumkommt. Der Fußball lebt ja davon, dass es an jeder Stelle einen Interessenskonflikt gibt, dass keiner den anderen so wirklich angreifen möchte. Das ist Gianni Infantinos Nähe zu Karlheinz Rummenigge ist bekannt, seine Nähe zu Eva, wo er herkommt, ist relativ klar, auch wenn Herr Schäferin sich im Moment ein bisschen gegen ihn positioniert. Aber auch da erwarte ich eigentlich nicht, dass es zu einem klaren Bruch kommt. Die Europäer haben Infantino in seine Machtposition gebracht. Das heißt, sie werden nicht diejenigen sein, die ihn jetzt dort mit aller Macht wieder wegkegeln. All diese Punkte sind ja ganz entscheidend dafür, dass es schwierig ist, dass externe Untersuchungen aus dem Fußball heraus Gianni Infantino wirklich in Bedrängnis bringen. Und die internen Untersuchungsmöglichkeiten, die hat er ja durch die Abschaffung von Bobbily und von Eckart, also durch die Abschaffung der Ethikkammer und der rechtsprechenden Kammer, im Prinzip ausgehebelt. Er hat mit Frau Rochas jetzt jemanden installiert. Das haben wir ja in epischer Breite versucht zu beschreiben, wie machtlos diese Frau eigentlich ist, die auch der Sprachen nicht mächtig ist, deren Englisch nicht gut genug ist, die Komfranzösisch sprechen kann, die aber genau in diesen Verkehrssprachen in der Lage sein soll, Urteile zu entwickeln oder bzw. Anklagen zu entwickeln. Das ist nahezu ausgeschlossen, dass so etwas funktioniert. Fatma Zamora als Generalsekretärin ist auch nicht die starke Person, die Gianni Infantino wirklich dort auch nochmal zur Rede stellen würde und sagen würde, das müssen wir jetzt aufklären, damit müssen wir uns jetzt beschäftigen. Der Fußball hat es ja noch nicht mal geschafft, von Gianni Infantino tatsächlich die Aussagen zu bekommen, wer hinter diesem Project Trophy als Geldgeber steht. Selbst das ist ja am Ende, der hat es sich einfach verweigert. Der hat dieses Angebot in die Gesprächsrunde reingeworfen und hält daran ja fest und lässt es ja immer wieder in den Zirkeln der UEFA diskutieren. Aber er hat bis heute nicht offen gelegt, nicht transparent offen gelegt, wer sind die Geldgeber dahinter? Wer sind diejenigen, die tatsächlich einen solchen Trust aufbauen wollen?
Ja, der sollte sowieso inzwischen mehr als schüttert sein. Lass uns noch über ein Thema kurz sprechen, nämlich den man finde, man kann tatsächlich sagen, den Kinderhandel mit Fußballspielenden Jugendlichen. Da haben wir nämlich unter anderem auch in einer Doku, die jetzt kürzlich lief, gelernt. Da hat Manchester City mal wieder in unrühmlicher Art und Weise seine Hände mit im Spiel. Aber wir können auch hier in Deutschland über einige Fälle zumindest reden. Kurz, was hat Manchester City gemacht? Seit 2010 investiert man jährlich mit mehr als einer Million Euro in eine Fußballschule in Ghana. Und das Wort Investment ist hier auch richtig, denn das wird von City selbst in internen Papieren als Venture Capital, also eben als Kapitalanlage bezeichnet. Denn man hat zuerst Zugriff auf diese Spieler, sobald die 18 Jahre alt werden, kann man sie zu Manchester City holen, wenn sie denn den entsprechenden Qualitätsstandard erfüllen. Oder eben, man kann sie zu anderen Mannschaften verleihen. Und da gibt es dann eine Dreiecksvereinbarung mit dem dänischen FC Nordjelland. Spieler gehen dorthin, dürfen dann nur mit Genehmigung von City weiterverkauft werden. Und wenn sie gut genug sind, wechseln sie kostenlos zu City. Und das, was Nordjelland davon hat, ist ein Teil der Ablösesumme. Jetzt muss man dazu kurz den rechtlichen Rahmen wieder erklären. Man darf nicht mit Jugendlichen, die Fußball spielen, Geld verdienen, bis diese vorjährig sind. Und jetzt haben wir hier, im Fall von Manchester City und gleich noch einem anderen, den ich dann gleich noch erzählen werde, ein jetzt dokumentierter Fall, wo diese juristische Vorgabe ausgehebelt wird. Was kann jetzt dagegen getan werden?
Also ich finde es erstmal wahnsinnig schade, dass wir nicht mehr wirklich viel Zeit haben, um dieses Thema näher auszusprechen.
Ich auch.
Ich bin gleich in dem nächsten Termin. Wenn dieses Thema die Zuhörer des Rasenfunks interessiert und dich auch interessiert, dann empfehle ich euch dafür auch nochmal Christoph Winterbach zu befragen, denn er war derjenige, der dieses Thema federführend für uns recherchiert hat und der dazu sehr viel zu sagen hat. Ich selbst habe auch in den letzten Jahren sehr viel über den Kinderhandel im Fußball geschrieben und habe über Fälle geschrieben, bei denen ich gesehen habe, wie insbesondere afrikanische Nachwuchsfußballer, wie Handelsware von einem Ort zum anderen geschickt wurden. Über das System, das wir jetzt im aktuellen Spiegel beschreiben und auch das, was der NDR in seiner Dokumentation gezeigt hat, diese Dreiecksbeziehung mit Manchester City, muss ich persönlich sagen, hat mich selten so dermaßen angefasst, weil man dort schlicht und ergreifend wirklich sehen kann, dass der Zionismus im Fußball kaum Grenzen kennt. Weil man dann sieht, dass solche jungen Fußballer in der Masse, in der Häufigkeit, in der Größenordnung aus Afrika hier hingeholt werden, nach Europa geholt werden, hier in Europa dann auch nochmal weiter verschickt werden.
Zum Teil gegen ihren Willen offenbar?
Und sie es selbst heute sogar noch bestätigen und sagen, wir wollten das nicht. Und Fußballer, die jetzt sagen, jetzt sind wir frei, wir sind weg aus den Verträgen und sind jetzt frei, nachdem das funktioniert hat. Andere junge Fußballer in Afrika, die vor der Kamera sagen, ich vermisse meine Eltern, ich vermisse meine Familie, die aber als Investment und als Kapitalanlage von europäischen Clubs benutzt werden. All das sind Dinge, über die wir normalerweise das nächste Tribünengespräch machen müssten, auch in der Länge, weil das etwas ist, was, wenn man sich den Fußball jetzt in unterschiedlichen Ebenen anguckt, wir haben lange darüber gesprochen, wie systemkaputt die Verbände sind, wie problematisch der Umgang der Vereine mit den Verbänden und auch untereinander ist, wie extrem das Kapital über ethische, moralische und gesetzliche Ebenen im Sport steht. Dann kommen wir irgendwann natürlich an die unterste Grenze, und die unterste Grenze ist eben dann der Nachwuchsbereich und der Nachwuchshandel. Wir haben ja im Spiegel auch eine lange Geschichte über Pinyas Sahavi, der als einer der erfolgreichsten Berater der Welt agiert und der auf die gleiche Art und Weise mit Jugendspielern hantiert und dort Jugendspieler transferrechte erwirbt über Firmen, die dann verteilt werden und diese Spieler in dieser Abhängigkeit, diese Firma gelagert werden. Also all das, ich mache jetzt einen sehr, sehr schnellen Überflug, aber all das müsste man jetzt normalerweise noch lange ausdiskutieren. Dieses Thema ist ja eines der zentralen Themen, wenn wir uns dazu Gedanken machen, wie durchsetzt der Fußball mit so fehlerhaften Entwicklungen ist. Und da betrifft er diejenigen, die sich nahezu nicht wehren können, und zwar Kinder.
Genau, absolut. Und weißt du, was genau das werden wir tun? Ich werde nicht nur Christoph, sondern auch noch ein paar anderen da einige Mails schicken. Das muss im Rasenfunk nochmal stattfinden. Ich kann an der Stelle nur nochmal sehr auch die Doku empfehlen, die es da im Sportclub gab. Am 11. November wurde die ausgestrahlt von Katrin Kampling und Nino Seidel. Wird noch eine Weile in der Mediathek verfügbar sein. Und vielleicht ja auch noch länger bei YouTube. Es wird definitiv verlinkt werden. Und wir werden dieses Thema noch hier abhandeln und dann auch aufklären, was haben da eigentlich Kai Havertz mit zu tun. Oder andere Spieler auch, die zum Beispiel bei Borussia Dortmund dann mal waren, oder die hingewechselt sind zu Rasenball Sport Leipzig. Das muss jetzt als Teaser genügen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schaut euch die Doku an. Und wir müssen, auch wenn das manchmal wehtut, denn manche Szenen dieser Doku sind auch wirklich nicht leicht zu ertragen, wenn da 10-jährige Kinder erzählen, dass sie doch ihre Mama schon sehr vermissen. Und wir dann wissen, wie ihre Perspektive ist. Es ist kein schönes Thema, aber wir müssen manchmal auch dahin gucken. Und man kann ja danach dann wieder mit Netflix sein Hirn wieder reinwaschen von solchen schlechten Einflüssen. Rafael, ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast, trotz deines sehr vollen Terminkellen. Ja, und natürlich auch an die Zuhörerinnen. Ich freue mich wieder auf die Diskussion, die es sicher auch wieder dazugeben wird. Auf mitmachen.rasen.de At rafanelli heißt Rafael bei Twitter und er antwortet da auch gerne auf Fragen. Wir haben ja auch gehört, dass alles ist ein wichtiger Teil dieser Football Leaks Enthüllung. Euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, herzlichen Dank vor allem allen Supporterinnen und Supportern. Ich habe sehr viel Zeit in die Vorbereitung hier gesteckt. Warum konnte ich das tun? Weil ihr mich finanziert. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Macht's gut.
Danke.